let's let's jump to the story from the
hill and then we'll start getting into
all that stuff we have this uh the hill
story DeSantis Administration launched
his investigation into holiday drag show
then there's a I I'm not sure if I have
pulled it up but Geraldo Rivera was like
what why are they going after drag
performances it's like yo
this guy doesn't read the news and
that's the challenge I'm not mad at
Geraldo I mean you can be mad at him you
criticize him for a lot of things but
the only store he he sees gets filtered
for the mainstream media and they say
DeSantis targets drag show what they
don't say in the headline is that the
drag show had children there and they
were explicitly warned by the Florida
government not to have children at the
event when they found out kids were at a
drag show with sexualized performances
that it was uh I don't know if it was a
sentence explicitly but it's the dbpr
was like okay we're going to be
investigating this because we told you
not to have kids there it's illegal they
say the Florida Department of Business
and Professional Regulation on Wednesday
announced it was investigating a holiday
themed drag show in South Florida
they said it was sexually explicit and
marketed to children
the department is actively investigating
the matter including video footage and
photographs from the in from the event
the statement said the department plans
to share any evidence collected into
investigation with the State Department
of Law Enforcement and criminal
liability look I'm I'm surprised it's
taking this long to deal with this stuff
and it's like the best we get right now
this is Florida of all places where they
had an all ages drag show where there's
videos of children there and it is it
like there there's men humping each
other on stage there's there's uh um
sexual organs displayed secondary sexual
organs this on display for people to
look at and little kids I post a lot
about drag shows and I'll just say this
was one of the worst ones I've ever seen
I was talking to James Lindsay when we
were at TP USA and I was like look
this was before we went on stage then we
brought up a gun stage and I was like
first it was drag queen Story Hour and
they kept saying it's just reading a
book calm down my response was drag is a
sexualized performance if you took a
stripper a go-go dancer wearing their
outfit before they take it off and have
them read for kids go go dancer Story
Hour would that be appropriate oh that's
totally different it's totally different
I'm like same thing the Go-Go dancer's
not naked but that makes no sense why
would you do it then they started doing
all ages drag shows it's just dancing
calm down they're just just dancing then
we saw that one where it said it's not
going to lick itself on the wall they're
talking about ice cream you're paranoid
now they have simulated sodomy and overt
sex acts in front of children they also
have strippers by the men in front of
kids well there's a few videos of that I
mean when where is this gonna end Dragon
stripping is not the same it's not but
they'll do both for kids and then money
being shoved down People's Clothing
which is also like what are you doing
like I think it's clear explicit
grooming yeah so this is exactly this is
what I was telling James Lindsay I'm
like it hits it hits grooming on the
head like hits the nail on the head with
a hammer it starts with all we're doing
is reading books introducing the concept
in the most innocent of ways so you can
plausible deniability just reading books
then you start dancing while I read the
books we're just dancing then you
eventually get into the full drag
performance it's it's fine it's just a
it's a fashion show then you get into
the heart of what it truly is is meant
to be for these people and it's
sexualized sodomy Etc and now they're in
it full swing that was the point that
was The Grooming and it worked they
weren't just grooming kids they were
grooming the parents to thinking it was
okay to bring their they're grooming the
media too yeah by the way no they admit
that themselves at the point of drag is
to queer kids they admit that yeah James
Lindsay posts this study yeah it's
that's something that's the paper they
actually wrote it themselves saying the
goal is to put glitter in a carpet that
can never be removed to get it in the
brains of these children they they admit
their grooming but they need people you
know in these these activists in the
media to lie to cover it up yeah and
they'll happily go along when you said
this was the worst uh drag show so far
that you've seen was that just
graphically like nature sexual sexually
yes Graphics did you see the footage of
it I don't think so there was like there
was someone on there with massive
massive fake breasts totally exposed we
can't show it they were saying no you'll
get the video will go men you know
thrusting into each other and things
like that the kids were there yeah I
can't show it on YouTube kids were there
okay kids were being interviewed kids
were putting were put on the stage and
on camera they were asked talked to well
so so there's one part where one of the
drag performers is talking about over at
sex acts that they engage in there's
children sitting right in front then
there then they ask the child what's
your favorite part of the event this was
in Texas and the kid's like nothing it's
like these parents are bringing these
kids there yeah because the parents were
groomed and legally speaking if a parent
takes a kid to a over 18 movie they're
allowed right with a parent I'm asking
genuinely with parental Guardian are
they allowed to see porn or kid no 13
year old nope the parents then convicted
of something if they expose 13 year old
to it not porn I don't know the exact
law we've had people mention enticement
of a minor or there's exploitation laws
about entry like if you go up to a child
as an adult even your child and start
showing them graphic images
depending on the context right if you if
if a parent brings a book on the birds
and the bees and to be honest even a
book like genderqueer it No One's Gonna
arrest a parent for being like I want to
show you a book and explain these things
to you I think you're ready but if a
parent goes to a kid and shows them
overt like pornographic hardcore stuff
that's when you're getting to the line
Child Services yeah kids get being
forced to watch that stuff yeah and if
an adult who's uh here's here here's the
like look there's a challenge I think
most people might agree with when a
parent decides it's time to talk to
their kids about the birds and the bees
and in what form that will be
I don't think the form of that is
showing your kids hardcore porn
obviously but there may be some people
who argue well you know these kids are
going to experience these things on the
internet and they got to be warned about
it it's like okay finding that line I'll
admit is it's going to be difficult for
the law to figure out I think we as
moral human beings like in this room and
people watching can clearly say you know
when you see it don't show it to kids
but for the law to figure out it's going
to be a lot harder
now the problem here is these are
strangers if a parent brought their kid
to a strip club they're going to get
arrested and charged they're endangering
a child period hands down the issue is
it's cultural
a cop seeing a kid at a strip club is
going to be like this parent brought a
kid to a strip club the bar is in
trouble eight the 21 and up the parents
in trouble but because it's drag it's
under that protected flag so the cops
are going I'm such a pathetic scared
piece of garbage I won't actually do
anything so these cops are just standing
back and saying nothing I think that's
the problem is that drag is like if I
came in here was wearing a dress tonight
I'd be in drag there's no sexuality I
mean you could argue that there's but
you can do that asexually but when they
start to take off clothing even a a
sleeve or simulating taking off clothing
then stripping or stripping each other
like rabbit dogs that's blatant or sex
you know zipping a fake unzipping down
no no no no unzipping a fake female
organ to birth something on stage in
front of children any kind of unzipping
I would argue with strip that's what
they were that's what they did so
stripping is different than drag and if
you're showing kids sniping that's
another conversation in no the same
thing well you can wear a dress and not
strip yes but drag performances this is
what the left has been our lizard for
instance the left has been claiming that
drag it's not stripping they're taking
their clothes off on stage for a custom
change and it's like that's tripping
yeah if you're taking your clothes off
it's interesting they're just playing
semantics to manipulate to groom and
DeSantis is saying Eddie Izzard he was
famous comedian still is that uh would
wear women's clothing he dressed and
drag for his comedy shows but he's just
straight up a dude no he's a guy no he's
full you're right Eddie Izzard is full
on trans right now oh really yeah yeah
Eddie Izard for like 20 years was just a
dude that would wear makeup and a dress
and do comedy so if a kid saw that I
don't think there's anything immoral
about it it's just Eddie expressing
himself well this isn't the only uh
story that DeSantis Eddie Izzard is
gender fluid using the word transgender
uh
I don't know yep trans woman Eddie
izzard's been out as trans for a while
now I wonder what the next psyop's going
to be against the governor of Florida
since just a couple months ago we had
the whole don't say gay bill that the
whole country was talking about that all
the celebrities were talking about that
literally just allowed kindergarters to
have parental consent when talking about
these topics and again they they lied
about it they're probably going to be
lying about this they're going to
probably run another psyop about this
and it's interesting seeing Ron DeSantis
at the head of a lot of these
controversies he also knows that this is
this is important that this is a bigger
cultural war and he also was involved in
local school races he also made sure
that Local School Board elections uh had
a lot of his support and uh things are
definitely changing in Florida but I I
do see him as as one of the major uh
kind of uh people that will be attacked
in 2023 I don't know what do you think
no for sure I mean he's definitely at
the Forefront of all these issues it's
incredible to watch I wish more people
would look at him and take cues from him
you know other governors
um but there is I wanted to mention that
other video I don't know if you remember
it there was a viral video of a stripper
walking down I guess the stage holding a
little child's hand so that was in
Florida and they actually lost their
liquor license wow yeah like DeSantis is
really taking these things seriously oh
that's great he's not and now we have
this in Florida too so I think you know
I think it's a matter of time until we
see
um something something happened where
this is not gonna be allowed in Florida
anymore we are opening a venue as I
mentioned uh several times now and we
actually second guessed whether or not I
was going to do it
one of the reasons was to put it simply
the economy is going to implode in a
catastrophic collapse in the next 60 to
90 days so people have told me but uh
when we're looking at buying this
property you know we're hearing bad
things but there was another issue not
too far away was a venue that had an
all-ages drag show for Halloween or
something like that and then I was just
like
I don't know if I want to open a
business in an area that's doing
something like that next to a venue that
would allow that and then I thought
about it now was like
this is West Virginia
I think if we
are to open this venue it would insulate
this area to prevent things like this
because if any one of these venues tries
to do something like that again
we will just hold our own event and
invite everyone down to come hang out
and then be like we're in a peacefully
have our voices be heard by hanging out
having coffee doing our own event and
and putting pressure on the city to not
allow all ages shows uh sex shows just
not going to happen we need that
presence to stop it retreating wouldn't
make sense we have to push back right
well I'll just say if if you're looking
for a place where there's no drag shows
it's going to be basically impossible to
find
it's in every I don't care about drag
shows for kids I'm saying for characters
for kids yeah yeah shout out to Jack
Huger of The Young Turks who said if he
had the money he'd put on the biggest
drag show ever and the first thing I
thought was like what do you mean if you
had the money like dude's a millionaire
What's it gonna cost to put on a big
drag show you know you can get a 3 000
seater venue your total cost is going to
be like 30 to 40 Grand I know it's a lot
of money but not for The Young Turks
their Network they can't afford that
okay fine I said we'll do it this is
gonna be awesome Tim cast is going to
sponsor one of the coolest drag shows
ever there's going to be you know it's a
free admission it's going to be funny
there will be comedy there will be an
epic performance free food free booze of
course with booze of course it's 21 and
over only but uh it'll be great no and
everyone's like yeah okay great yeah
you're gonna go do what you want right
disappear to all of a sudden they're
just like not interested what's how
about just open a strip club be old
school be old school about it no but
like I don't care about drag shows I
actually think they are nobody cares
about drag shows till they started
involving kids yeah and I I don't think
anybody still cares about drag shows
it's just the kids the kids yeah and
then they they say I think Jack was like
you know they don't really care because
they don't care about Hooters and I'm
like yo I don't like Hooters
what's wrong with voters
exploitative women I don't mind your
opinion making them wear tight outfits
of women with big boobs trying to sell
food women women choose to work they're
allowed to work there I don't think it's
appropriate place for kids to go eat
strip clubs exist some of them have food
don't care go to a strip club if you
want to go strip club I don't I'm not
it's not my thing full disclosure I like
the buffalo wings at Hooters of course
you do I always liked them I've only had
them I never believed that well have you
had one out yes good buffalo sauce you
didn't think so oh absolutely not this
is like 2006 or five like my whole life
when I'm younger I'm hearing from all my
dude friends like well no we should go
to I mean the wings are actually really
good at Hooters and I'm like it's a
sauce I'm like is that for real or are
they just saying that because I want to
see boobs and then like I go with them
and I'm like yo These Wings suck
I'm like thanks thanks a lot of my wings
I I it felt very weird
I just don't think it's right for kids I
don't like children beauty pageants yeah
those are those yeah they're always like
oh call a beauty pen just yeah sure
where I'm against that too yeah not
appropriate for kids yeah
but I will say this too bringing some
young boys to a restaurant where you're
upset that women wear clothing dude if
the kids went to the beach they would
see more boobs than they would see at
Hooters I'm not going to demand Hooters
be shut down because the women have have
low cut tops women have boobs boys will
see them whether that Hooters or at the
beach or walking around hey be inclusive
here uh Bill Gates has boobs men could
have boobs too my point is he got the
vegan moves two and I'll put it this way
here's my hierarchy of like how bad it
is Hooters yeah you shouldn't bring kids
to a place called Hooters where the
intent is that the the the waitresses
have big tits hanging out but little
boys are going to see big tits walking
down the street so I'm not crying about
it then you've got child beauty pageants
okay these are little girls like 10
years old covered in makeup and wearing
dresses and being told to shake their
hips I'm like that's you no I don't I
don't like that at all that I would say
not a fan of probably shouldn't be doing
that then you get to the the Florida
style or the Texas style drag shows
we've seen where men are thrusting into
each other singing a song about
screwdolph banging dudes and it's like
children should definitely not be there
and that should be a crime I think
calling it a drag show is is a
disservice to the movement because it's
a sex show at that point yes wait
there's a there's another level on top
of that which kids themselves are the
drag queens so we're talking about Minor
yeah like the NBC News had that uh Good
Morning America had uh you know a young
child children stripping for money at a
gay bar where men threw money at the
little boy taking Justin wasn't that
guy's name Desmond Desmond Desmond that
was the first I saw at 2015 or something
is that right and then there are so many
now didn't they do like a TV show about
drag games or something yeah it's like
okay yeah that's grooming dude
I'm not taking he's talking about doing
ketamine too yeah snorting it like
didn't he like do a bumper like a
simulated dude like people were saying
how does that little that 10 year old
kid know how to simulate doing drugs up
the nose snoring drugs thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time